hi I'm Robert rich Nakia and my question
was based on your experience
as with the s and CC and in the civil
rights movement what do you find most
effective in social movements and what
qualities do you think allow them to
have the greatest impact be most
effective at raising money raising money
and having impact in a general sense let
me concentrate on raising money in the
early 1960s you could raise enormous
sums of money through the mail that's
still true today but it's less true than
it was then and to the degree that we
could I can remember spending hours and
hours folding letters stuffing them in
envelopes caring and stamping them one
by one you know we didn't have machines
one by one carrying them to the post
office send them off and then waiting
for the money to come back in and almost
every time the money did come back in
and now we're not talking about millions
here we're talking about thousands and
lo thousands but we've always got enough
money to keep our doors open to keep our
staff paid to take care of whatever
problems we had I say that's less true
now because people are less likely to
give money through the mail there's a
shrinking population of people who will
do that today and so you've got to raise
money in other ways internet fundraising
has begun to take some of the place of
that if you're able to have a large list
of people you can write to on the
internet and say some crisis's but just
look what's in the news lately today the
Susan G Komen ants Cancer Fund cut off
support to Planned Parenthood because of
pressure from right-wing Republicans and
a hue and cry went up around the United
States
Mayor Bloomberg of New York City paid
out of his pocket to make up for the
money they had but individual Americans
just swelled the Treasury of Planned
Parenthood because they were outraged at
this having happened so sometimes you
can turn a tragedy into a benefit as
happened in this case but as I was
driving here to the studio I heard on
the radio that the Susan G Komen
Association has changed his mind popular
pressure was too much they realized
they'd done something stupid and tried
to best - corrected by reversing it
so tactics that worked well in my day
work less well or the tactic worked best
my day works less well here but it still
works and their substitute tactics and
you've got to work on them same is true
with social activism marching protesting
sitting in these are tried-and-true
techniques you can use it if you're for
me or against me
either way it works but they don't work
with the same strength that they did
then they work but they don't work as
well as you so you have to find other
ways to do it other reason to it and
again the internet plays a big role here
you've seen internet petitions signed
this petition stopped Joe from doing
what he wants to do or make Joe do what
he wants to do or doesn't want to do and
you may or may not sign them but there
as as soon as one method seems to
diminish another one appears and I think
quick people who are quick minded in the
activist community know how to shift
from this to this to this to this and
take up some of the means and method